il est grand et majestueux et à ses
propres fans la star du jour c'est ce
châtaignier de la celle saint cloud fier
de ses 18 mètres d'envergure il pose
devant les appareils photos des
yvelinois venus en grand nombre pour le
voir la raison il vient de remporter le
titre de l'arbre de l'année je les ai
vus dans les magazines mais je me suis
dit je vais le prendre en photo moi mais
ce châtaignier fait partie d'une
présentation qui a été faite sous louis
xiv y avait 350 châtaignier dans ce
quartier c'est le seul survivant il
était exploité pour deux choses d'une
part pour les châtaignes on faisait la
farine de châtaigne pour se nourrir et
par ailleurs comme il y avait des vignes
sur les coteaux de la région parisienne
et dans ce quartier en particulier on
était régulièrement là pour faire les
échalas qui sont les piquer support des
17 de vigne un arbre qui surprend les
curieux visiteurs par son physique il
fait quand même quatre mètres de large
et les normes il a une très grande
envergure et il est beau je reviendrai
le vent avec des feuilles les corses
elle est très très bon je trouvais très
vivant pour que les copains d'accord
c'est très belle très saine les branches
sont sont très harmonieuse et puis le
trou n'est quand même un spécial il
évrier et puis l'a 350 ans ce chat
théniers âgée de trois cent trente ans
est situé dans un quartier résidentiel
au nom tout trouvé la châtaigneraie il
n'y a pas que moi qui suis fier
l'ensemble de la vie des fiers les gens
du quartier tout particulièrement
puisque c'est le symbole de leur
association une association de quartier
très très vivante qui connaît bien cet
art qui le surveillent attentivement en
espérant qu'ils tombent pas malades que
ses angles ses branches seront pas cassé
il a 330 en châtaignier ça peut vivre
milan donc sa prochaine étape c'est de
doubler le nombre
l'année qui la déchire et ce n'est pas
fini pour lui il représentera la france
au concours de l'arbre de l'année
européen en 2022